as a working professional your
experience matters a lot but at times
that is not enough you require a bit of
push to excel in your career this
Certification did that for me right
after I completed my certification I got
a 50 hike in my new job as a senior
business analyst hi my name is Abhishek
Sani and I came to Canada in 2015 to
pursue a course in 2015 itself I got a
job at a company called ifds
International financial data services as
a business analyst in 2020 I decided to
move on with my career and I joined a
company called ssnc as an application
analyst it was going great but I wanted
to explore more I wanted to grow both
professionally and financially therefore
I decided to pursue a course from Simply
learn which was post graduate program
business analysis from Purdue University
that course really helped me it taught
me the basics of business analysts the
foundations of business analyst and also
the tools that Bas use in their
day-to-day life and it was a promising
course that really Advanced my career
and right after the course was over I
joined LTI Mind Tree as a senior
business analyst with a 50 hike in my
salary I had a great time while
attending the course it gave me the
tools and the mindset to pursue my
career and Advance my career and also
grow my career financially the mentors
were great I had a great time
interacting with them and understanding
the real world experiences and not only
that but the overall missing thing that
I was having in my career
simply learn was able to plug that and I
was able to excel in my career as I said
I was able to get 50 hike in my new
company right after I got to
certification from Simply learn in my
current profile I'm working in the agile
framework and I'm applying the knowledge
that I got from Simply learn and I'm
able to succeed in my career as well so
I would like to thank you simply learn
for assisting me with the course and
making my career a success I believe it
happened because of my experience and
the certification I got from Simply
learn I'm really happy with the respect
of where I am in my career right now
foreign